this year though we came to win for one
thing I've got my dude everyone's
bringing boot up and season two there's
some really interesting pairings that
happen that I don't I wouldn't have
expected so we're gonna assume the
characters new romances within the group
there's romances it's all unexpected
should I hope you know being adorable
don't fight it fight it
Zuka is happening or everyone's boot up
repair sufficient now baby you and
though we are finally official your
Paris official big fax no we have to
celebrate official official our live but
are we gonna see the honeymoon phase
kind of phase out at some point you guys
don't know if they even had a honeymoon
phase and yet we went straight into
summer yeah you know she makes a big
decision and then we go on break and so
it's an interesting moment you know now
that I think all that settled and I know
for sure that they're together just
great too because we have the duality of
them being a relationship but also them
being innocent frankly you know it's the
trials and tribulations of Zoe Johnson
and right you know what pacifist I'm her
boyfriend now it's so funny because
she's so unlike me she is very
meticulous and serious like wants to get
things done and kind of just like smoke
and we know we're all gonna do something
we've never done before yeah you're
gonna see Aaron and Anna fighting a lot
politically so there's definitely a lot
of hot topics that we're gonna touch
that this is just the next year
sophomore year you know Zoe Lucas still
going strong Aaron is the RA now of
Hawkins trying to you know still pushes
political agenda while also loving the
single life I don't know if that kid can
be true why can't you just admit that
guys get upset over breakups - Zoe it's
still not the same so much of the season
was Zoe and Luka and then Zoe and Aaron
trying to even figure out and Zoe and
cash and
Oh trees oh really
why are we not going to see Yaris
ex-boyfriend da Vinci this season I
think we're not gonna see him because I
mean I mean from Aaron's douche bag I
don't see cash being the next that comes
back this season is is there any truth
to that - da Vinci he's on TV I thought
it was a known fact
you know I again I'm not gonna be the
weak link
so you're not gonna steal any chance you
talk to either you two about us getting
back together
any rebound relationships because
normally that's what happens after
heartbreak are we gonna off the top of
my head I can't think of one but who
knows what the right Trevor is Aron
currently lying to me Erin doesn't like
Trevor goes sometimes just break your
heart don't you late for that her
friends helping her the same way we did
in season one okay I get an earful all
the time especially because I'm her
roommate do you really feel any better
Joey you are more like Zoe calm down
okay stop being selfish leave them alone
play hard to get
yeah we definitely are there her girls
for a lot of drama that happens so it's
me no me and Zoe so it's the three of us
living in a brand-new apartment which is
really funny because we all find ways to
afford it my girls are living together
so there's a lot of dynamics that's not
just now friends they're also roommate
yeah that's that's a whole bag of tricks
right there you know you guys are polar
opposites we're gonna butt heads a
little bit so yeah what can you say
about those intense scenes and what
topics that we gonna address personal
space and it's very conservative and a
little bit in the bubble and Nomi is not
it's very interesting just our very
first night there and yes and there
there are boundaries that I'm really
trying to to place and no II just here's
the opposite and she's like okay cool
more so more parties and I'm like I mean
of course Zoe and I live together first
season but the addition of Nomi and the
addition of just being in a new space
and also just being
new place in our lives yeah means that
all of that intersecting and now we have
this one big space for everyone to kind
of come together and they call oh my
gosh interesting storyline guy is the
cannon ball miss Susan we're left with
very few options don't seem to be
checking for us what's cool about the
season is that you really get to see
their individuality is in the first
season it was just you know us as the
two twins always together but you really
get their backstory then also we're just
discovering ourselves more in college as
athletes and just what we can take what
pressure we can take and what break says
it's fun so we like together nuts you
know with him being from Queens and
we're from south central here in Cali we
both have a little Hood in us so it's
pretty fun to play that and you also see
the softer side of jazz as well do you
really feel this this yearning for
something out of season one someone that
will work in your friend group I thought
would be sky it's really tough situation
when you're dating within friend groups
true right it's it's really dangerous
you don't wanna cross the line you don't
want to cross the line and if you do
it's a big thing and then if you do is
hard to go back any love for you this
season I'm hoping so I'm hoping so I put
it out in the humorous no is single okay
she wouldn't never mess with it I'm
sorry
luggage or it in but like Rebecca's a
little much you know cook for the drugs
and stuff they do say opposites attract
though so that would be funny
oh that would be crazy yeah I'll be
shocked no I think you just put a pitch
out there
due to a unique new educational frontier
man Charlie this season is on a whole
nother page he is promoted from and then
being - I mean from from being a box
professor to now being so now he is like
off the walls with it can you take your
future as serious with Dean Charlie now
I that was the funniest reveal to me
when I read my open defer script and I
was that Dean telphy possibly the most
brilliant thing I've ever heard realize
I mean homeboy is just like as a teacher
it was already so messy but as somebody
who is literally in charge of students
no I know I know and it's only up from
here guys
[Music]